welcome back we've been looking at
observability and now we're actually
going to see which sensor measurements
for the inverted pendulum on a cart give
us an observable system ok so just
recall we have a cart that can move left
and right we have an inverted pendulum
on that cart and this pendulum could be
in the up position which is unstable or
it could be hanging in the down position
which is kind of like a gantry crane
where it moved left and right this
system had four states it had X X dot
theta and theta dot this is kind of our
big vector state X and we derived the
nonlinear systems of equations and we
also looked at the linearization in the
up position and the down position okay
so we got a linear system X dot equals
ax plus B u this is for the linearized
dynamics about either the pendulum up or
pendulum down condition so a would be a
four by four linear matrix in this case
u our input is a force on the cart and
so B is a four by one column vector and
we showed that you can stabilize the
inverted pendulum dynamic by developing
a controller but now we're going to be
looking at when we have measurements y
equals CX how for what measurements y
equals CX can I back out what the full
state of the system was okay and so
again just to remind everybody you just
have to do with the observability matrix
OBS V a comma C is what it is in MATLAB
and if this observability matrix has
full rank then you can essentially build
an estimator to estimate X just for
measurements of Y and so the most
popular estimator is the Kalman filter
ok so let's try a few different
measurements see and see if if the
system is or is not observable ok ok so
I'm going to pull up MATLAB
and notice here just like in the last
time we define our system parameters I'm
going to look at the pendulum let's say
we want to look at the pendulum up
position just to start with so I have my
linearized dynamics in a my actuator
input in B and now what we're going to
do is we're going to pick a sensor we're
going to measure let's say one of these
variables so let's say C equals let's
say I want to measure just the x
position ok so just the x position would
be C equals zero one zero zero zero okay
so let's write this out if I had let's
say C equals 1 0 0 0 then if I take the
transpose of this X vector I see I have
X X dot theta and theta dot and so this
C measurement matrix just measures X the
the scalar position of the cart little X
of T ok and what we're going to see is
whether or not this measurement of just
the position of the cart is enough to
dynamically back out all of the other
variables X dot theta and theta dot ok
so just like with controllability all I
have to do is define the a and the C
matrices and then I can type in OBS be a
comma C so I'm going to type that in so
that we see the outputs and then we're
going to look at the determinant of OBS
be a comma C to make sure that it's full
rank okay so if it has a determinant
then it's going to be full rank now I'm
just going to run this code and we're
going to see in the output see if I can
lift this up really quickly let me just
type it in here
OBS be a comma C so this is the
observability matrix remember the
observability matrix is
Oh equal see then it should be three
times a C times a squared and C times a
cubed at least in this case okay so the
observability matrix again the first row
is in fact C this matrix here the next
row is C times a the third row is C
times a squared and the fourth row is C
times a cubed and because this is the
lower triangular matrix we can just spot
inspect that this thing has full rank or
it has a nonzero determinant in fact
this determinant is equal to four Det Oh
PSV a comma C and so what this tells us
right off the bat is that this
measurement I just measured the carts
position X then that system that linear
system is observable which means that I
can then use that single measurement to
back out all of the other state
variables in time and then I could use
that estimated state for full state
feedback control okay now let's just see
if some other measurements are also
observable or not so let's say instead
of measuring X I want to measure theta
okay so if I measure theta is the system
full state observable okay and if this
was a live class I'd ask how I'd ask you
all to vote how many of you think it's
observable how many of you think it's
not going to be observable but I'll just
run it to see okay so notice that my
determinant is equal to zero that means
it's definitely not observable so if I
measure only theta of T I can't estimate
every other state in time because my
determinant of my observability matrix
is zero meaning my observability matrix
OBS B of a comma C is not full rank and
so to look at this we actually look at
the observability matrix here and we see
exactly why it's not full rank okay in
particular notice that this entire first
column corresponding to the
of T variable is all zeros and this kind
of makes sense remember when we derive
the system of equations
none of the equations none of these X
dot equations actually depended directly
on this cart position X okay so
everything depended on theta X dot theta
dot right those things actually create
forces but the system doesn't care if my
cart is here or here or here okay so
it's translationally invariant meaning
that the the scalar position X of T
doesn't come in anywhere in the
equations and so if I don't directly
measure it I can't actually estimate the
carts position X of T and that's what it
says here is that basically there's this
whole column vector there's this whole
state given by the cart position that's
not observable if I measure theta of T
okay so if I really want to be alert to
stabilize this inverted pendulum on a
cart and I want to be able to walk it to
exactly some physical position let's say
I want to be able to move it left one
meter then I'd better measure the x
position because I can't infer it from
any of these other measurements okay so
that's kind of kind of neat all right so
what we're going to do next time is
we're going to go back and use this
measurement of the carts position X of T
we're going to use this measurement that
was observable and based on that single
measurement Y we're going to build a
common filter to estimate all of X all
of the state X at all times and then
we're going to use that estimated full
state again with lqr to stabilize the
system even with only one measurement
okay thank you